earlier this evening I was introduced by
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences who also
happens to be a distinguished
screenwriter and producer it's only fair
that I now reintroduce him to you for
purposes I'm certain he is capable of
explaining himself I give you mr.
Charles Brackett
following established procedure the
Academy Board of Governors met last
night and voted the honorary Awards and
others not covered by General balloting
the recipients of these awards were
notified earlier and they are waiting
backstage no longer in a state of shock
to present the special effects award
we've invited a young lady who is
herself a very special effect miss merle
oberon
I'm not a special effect but thanks for
the young lady part anyway a special
effect is a scene or sequence utilizing
miniature Azure trick photography to
bring to the screen those events which
would be too dangerous to reproduce
otherwise for example the sacking of
Rome for the eruption of Vesuvius or
crossing Hollywood and Vine against the
like the winner this year is the war of
the world
we'll accept with the paramount special
effects Department want to say on behalf
of paramount and George pal that the
this award is a group effort and I only
like to mention gordon jennings who was
not with us and george dutton and their
coworkers in visual and audible effects
who really did a magical job thank you
very much